سيده الميدان ربما صاحبه القتال البري
تورت عن الحروب الحديثه مؤخرا لتعود اليوم
بثقالها خطط استراتيجيه اوكرانيه باتت
الدبابات لا تغيب عنها استعدادا لشن عمليه
حاسمه او حتى لصد عمليه بريه كبرى قد
تشنها روسيا في الربيع القادم واقع عسكري
جديد يغير اهتمامات اوكرانيا من حرب
السماء الى الارض من الطائرات بدون طيار
والحرب السبرانيه وغيرها مما تعرف من
الاسلحه المتطوره الى البر والدبابات
بعد الحديث عن المرحله الجديده من الصراع
العسكري في الربيع القادم استفاقت
اوكرانيا عما تبقى لها من دبابات قديمه
تحتاج الى صيانه وصيانتها بيد الروس فقط
ما دفعك لتطلق نداءات الى اوروبا للمساعده
نداءات لبتها اولا فرنسا بتاكيد ارسال
دبابات خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 فيما
بريطانيا تعاهدت بتزويد اوكرانيا باربعه
عشره دبابه من طراز شالنجر كما ابدت
الولايات المتحده استعدادا بتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات او مدرعات وحدها المانيا
لم تتحرك اتجاه تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات من
طراز لو بارد الالمانيه المتقدمه كما لم
تسمح لاي دوله اخرى بتقديم هذه الدبابات
لاوكرانيا وخاصه كندا و بولندا قادته
الجيش الاوكراني يضغطون للحصول على 300
دبابه و600 مدرعه في لقلب الموازين عسكريه
خاصه في المناطق التي ضمتها روسيا لوغانس
ودونيتسك وجابوريجيا تتوفر الاسلحه ربما
قريبا لكن يبقى التحدي في مدى سرعه
استعداد الجيش الاوكراني وتدريبه لاستخدام
كل المعدات العسكريه الجديده
موسكو حذرت من الدعم الغربي الاخير
لاوكرانيا مؤكده ان اثره لن يكون سوا
اطاله امد معاناتك وشعبها في حرب بريه قد
تتسع مستقبلا غيداء سالم العربيه